liebe sally
zehn jahre youtube
sind vorüber wir haben die ganzen
geschaffen wir haben viele menschen
kennengelernt wir haben unglaublich
gegen gemacht was uns leute niemals
zugetraut hätten
mit dir zusammen durch dich es war
einfach gigantisch das ist ein video von
wegbegleitern von freunden von kollegen
die wir haben die dir etwas sagen möchte
zehn jahre und jetzt über zwei millionen
abonnenten du bist großartig und für das
haben wir dieses video hier gemacht
schau ist ja okay und ich weiß jetzt
schon es wird sehr sehr emotional und
ich weiß dass wir nicht mit ihr zusammen
anschauen 100 prozent
[Musik]
ich habe sie damals in der videothek
kennengelernt also ich bin ein bisschen
das wissen die wenigsten ein bisschen
filmfreak also ich liebe filme die heute
nicht mehr auf die alten mache ich es
ganz ganz arg und dann ich die saleen
diese videothek rhein gelaufen und hat
gesagt naja sie suchen jemand der die
flyer sponsert für die für die für die
für die abschlussfeier und hat dann bei
meinem kumpel dann aufgeschlagener
gesagt ob wir sie vielleicht
unterstützen könnten dadurch diese
kumpel angerufen sagt hey hier sind zwei
mädels und die haben eine abiturfeier
können wir irgendwie sponsern und die
eine die ich voll hübsch und sehr hübsch
gewesen wurde mal abgesehen und aber die
ist zu groß für dich und dann habe
gesagt okay ich komme vorbei dann reden
wir drüber
ich habe gesagt hey du bist der tür
gehen könntest du mir vielleicht diese
back klarmachen als als entschädigung
okay ich mache diese partner war und
dann kamen sie dann am nächsten tag
angelaufen dies sind ganz lieb so
richtig nah ich so richtig coolen haben
wir die baklava gebacken und s klasse
ist ich habe mir also ich glaub ich habe
mich von anfang an in sie verliebt ich
habe noch ein kumpel esther schavan und
als ich 15 oder 16mal zum star bank sagt
schavan hinzu eines tages wenn ich nicht
frau heiraten die schlauer ist als ich
und die größe ist als nicht dann hat er
schon damals zu mir gesagt den gibt es
übrigens immer noch den charme und der
macht den job in mannheim in sulz am
neckar zu mir gesagt meinte dazu für
dich eine frau zu finden die die größe
ist also das ist kein problem das wird
einfach aber eine frau die intelligenter
ist als du die wir niemals so ein
blödsinn wird dich heiraten und dann kam
es denn
[Musik]
zehn jahre servicewelt eine ganz ganz
klasse geschichte eigentlich als
angefangen wie gesagt vor zehn jahren
ich war noch person halb so ein bisschen
in der ausbildung und sally hat studiert
und zwar lernt ist grundschullehrerin
und es ist bis heute noch wir haben
damals bafög bekommt das weiß ich noch
und wohnungs beihilfe
und wir hatten nicht viel geld und die
sally beim studium und sie hatte als
arbeit oder als projekt was ihren
dozenten zeigen musste neue lernmethoden
und eine lernmethode was sie den
menschen unbedingt zeigen wollte war
youtube und irgendwann komme ich abends
nach hause und sehe wie sally in der
küche ein karton hingestellt hat und auf
dem karton so eine kleine digitale
kamera hat ich weiß ob wir sie gekostet
war es beim 69 eur und hat sich einfach
dabei gefilmt wie sie lustig macht
sallys anfänge auf youtube waren dann
tatsächlich so na also damals passen
auch nicht so dass man irgendwie youtube
gesagt hat und jeder wusste jetzt um was
für eine plattform sich da so zwingend
handelt das kann man sich heute
eigentlich gar nicht mal so vorstellen
weil eigentlich alle social media
begriffe so in jedermanns munde sind
aber damals war das echt noch so etwas
ganz neues und als sie mir das davon
erzählt auch da gibt's jetzt irgendwie
eine möglichkeit und sie wurde
tatsächlich einfach immer nach all ihren
rezepten gefragt und deswegen
tatsächlich so an dass wir dann das war
dann schon zur studiums zeiten dass sie
dann irgendwann die idee hatte ich
könnte doch um sozusagen mehrere
anfragen auf einmal zu stillen einfach
mal ein video darüber drehen weil es ist
ja dass einen rezept zu haben aber
gerade auch bei hefeteig musste ich ganz
lange auch nicht ist es ja auch eine
frage der zimmertemperatur der
reihenfolge der zutaten wie man was
hinzu gibt
da war es einfach so dass sie sich dann
in die küche gestellt hat ihre
lehrbücher als stativ benutzt hat sie
war schon immer sehr perfektionistisch
ohne perfektionistisch zu sein also sie
hatte dann einfach schon zu diesen
anspruch das licht muss passen der
winkel muss irgendwie passen und wir
haben dann gefühlt an 20 verschiedenen
stellen in der küche
lehrbuch im lehrbuch auf gestapelt
manchmal hat das buch dann 30 seiten zu
viele man musste dann ein schmaleres
nehmen dass es von der höhe gepasst hat
und ich glaube man kann sich vorstellen
um sallys höhe einzufangen hat man sehr
viele bücher gebraucht die sie gott sei
dank auch hatte ich hab dann so ein
bisschen dafür gesorgt dass die kamera
auch da bleibt wo sie bleibt und werden
immer so ein bisschen beratschlagt
ob das jetzt für laien eigentlich gut
nachvollziehbar ist ich war ja dann der
perfekte laie da das beurteilen konnte
verlängert tatsächlich von kochen und
backen zu diesem zeitpunkt und
vielleicht auch ein kleines bisschen
auch heute noch
weniger ahnung hatte als sie und das war
dann einfach auch eine ganz gute
abstimmung
und sie hatten einfach mit videos weiter
gemacht also ich bin immer zur arbeit
gekommen gegangen morgens um vier uhr
morgens raus zu arbeiten und sie hat
ihre videos weitergemacht und dann hat
sie am nächsten tag wieder eins gemacht
und wieder dran gearbeitet tage lang
diesen videos gearbeitet
und wir hatten damals auch schon die
samira die war schon ziemlich klein und
es geht bei immer knapp bei uns und ich
habe dann irgendwann so gemerkt nach
einem halben dreiviertel ja ich kann die
frau nicht aufhalten dann bin ich dann
zu kumpels gegangen den restaurant haben
und habe gesagt hör mal zu meine frau
macht so videos auf youtube unsicher was
ist youtube das ist eine plattform im
internet und das alles und die macht er
ganz tolle videos guckt es sind ihre
videos aber uns fehlt das geld für die
glee zutaten oder halt dass sie
weitermachen kann und habe ich sagt tun
mir eingefallen zahl nur die zutaten ich
bringe mich nur die kuchen zeit nur die
zutaten und dann haben die kumpels hat
der restaurantbetreiber hat dann gesagt
das geht nicht wir können nicht von
außerhalb kuchen annehmen und dann reich
bei den nachbarn geklingelt die haben
schon gefährdet ihr schon nicht mehr
aufgemacht weil weil ich sehr lieb
dauern
kuchen gebacken hat ich habe sie dann
wirklich ich habe dann sehr willig mit
engelszungen starts wir haben kein geld
hör auf damit wie auch immer und sie hat
ein jahr lang weiter gemacht und hat
sich dann nach einem jahr ungefähr nach
eineinhalb jahren hat sich bei youtube
aus versehen angemeldet und zwar nennt
sich das monika monetarisieren wenn ihr
werbung vor dem videos seht dann
bekommen wir etwas geld dafür das ist
nicht viel dafür wird man nicht reich
glaub mir durch youtube wird nicht reich
durch die monetisierung und als nach
eineinhalb jahren hat sie 50 euro
bekommen weil sich aus versehen
angemeldet hat und irgendwann kommt zu
mir und sagt zu mir kommen woran ich
habe 50 euro mit meiner frau wie
verdient und ich habe mein lachen müssen
habe ich sie gefragt wie videos
hochgeladen dann sagt sie zehn videos
oder 12 video ist ja und wie viel
stunden hast dafür verbraucht dann sagt
sie ja mit schneiden mit drehen so
ungefähr 200 dann sage ich du hast mit
200 stunden 50 euro verdient das ist
halt so es war so süß
so als lehrerin das ist eine ganz andere
welt und dann sagt schatz wenn du meine
dosen ravioli und strauchtomaten
in die regale eingeräumt hättest
dann hättest du mehr verdient
aber das besondere an er war immer
nicht damit geld verdient
sondern menschen etwas beizubringen das
war das besondere an ihrem damals was
tatsächlich so wir waren beide
noch am studierender so locker fröhlich
durchs leben gehüpft und ein karussell
mit der idee um die ecke du es gibt da
so eine sendung topfgeldjäger da würde
ich gern mitmachen und dann fahre ich
natürlich total begeistert so jahr
wunderbar das passt ja zu dir wie die
faust aufs auge ja was sie mir halt bis
zum schluss dann verschwiegen hat war ja
die sind da immer zu zweit
und ich bräuchte da noch jemand
[Musik]
der da mit mir hin geht und das
sozusagen bewerkstelligen und ich dachte
dann zunächst jahr gut sie wird jetzt
jeden meinen außer mich weil ich meine
ich war jetzt nicht bekannt für meine
koch und backkünste
aber sie meinte mich also bis wir
zusammen zu den top torjägern gegangen
sind vielleicht zweimal miteinander
gekocht und wenn ich sage ich habe
gekocht dann habe ich die kochlöffel
bedient das menü steht es steht der plan
steht wir sind vorbereitet
ich hätte das erstens für keinen anderen
menschen auf dieser welt getan
und das war einfach also wir haben dann
zusammen so
funktioniert weil wir uns da einfach
auch in der schnelligkeit der zeit
vertrauen mussten also wir konnten da
gar nicht miteinander sprechen und auch
gar nicht uns irgendwie miteinander
absprechen weil die zeiten ja einfach
auch so
eng getaktet wandersmann hätte daher
wirklich tatsächlich nur eine begrenzte
zeit zeit auch diese drei gerichte zu
kochen und wir haben uns einfach
vertraut wir haben da gas gegeben und
dann verging die zeit wie im flug und
irgendwie hat es funktioniert ja das
finanziell immer im vordergrund das war
einfach menschen etwas beizubringen das
besondere an dass sally ist immer ich
habe sie gefragt was machst du anders
als ein sternekoch als einen fernseher
kochen dann hat sie mir gesagt morath
man muss
komplizierte vorgänge also beim backen
ist auch so man muss sehr genau arbeiten
man muss komplizierte vorgänge so
didaktisch so runterbrechen dass es auch
kinder verstehen und wenn's kinder
verstehen ist jetzt wissen sexistischer
ich muss jetzt mal drüber lachen wenn es
kinder verstehen verstehen es auch
männer und da hat sie recht gehabt und
das tolle war ist anders hier einfach
wie sie dinge beibringen wie sie dinge
zeigt und dadurch
der kanal natürlich gewachsen und es
gibt verschiedene momente wo ich mich an
meine frau vielleicht noch mal verliebt
habe da gibt es auch so gewisse momente
bei der celebrity das ist so krass was
sie gemacht hat
[Musik]
ich glaube hier bin ich richtig da
laufen
glaubst du morasch
ich weiß noch ganz genau sie kam
strahlend auf mich zu und ich habe sie
genauso angestrahlt ja und wir haben ja
auch messen zusammen gemacht wo ich die
moderation gemacht habe und sie hatte
immer ganz klar sie wusste da sind
kinder da werden diese worte nicht
benutzt da ist das sind die sie hat
alles im blick gehabt das so wenn 56 700
leute vor mir stehen sie hat sie hat ein
masterplan und sie holt jeden ab sie
holt jeden ab ob
frau ob mann ob kintopp gehandicapte
menschen es ist jeder ein star bei der
rallye und das ist er wirklich weil sie
da bock drauf hat dass sie das macht und
es
ist für mich eigentlich eine leistung
plus dass sie immer noch auf den murat
nebenher aufpassen muss also wirklich
wahnsinn
natürlich haben wir auch über die ganzen
zehn jahre viele viele tolle menschen
kennengelernt auch viele viele tolle
unternehmen das wichtigste war für immer
uns für uns immer dass wir mit mit mit
unternehmen zusammenarbeiten die
gleichen werte teilen und auch keine
kurzfristige aktion machen oder sowas
einfach langfristig zusammenarbeiten
zusammenwächst und da gibt es viele
tolle menschen um uns herum zum beispiel
toni das ist der vertriebsleiter von
bosch der uns schon glaubst einsatz
sechs oder sieben jahren begleitet auf
der küchenmesse in köln
da hatten wir einstand als marke bosch
und ich kann mich erinnern sally ist da
aufgetreten und wir hatten ganz viele
kunden die zu uns auf den stand gekommen
sind und gesagt haben wahnsinn da vorne
ist eine youtube
und diese mit ihrem mann und der markt
geraten livestream unter gucken
20.000 leute zu
und es war ja damals noch irgendwie ja
ich sag mal noch nicht so in aller munde
und
ich sagte das wusstet ihr angucken das
ist ja wahnsinn 20.000 leute leid
livestream auf facebook alles glaube ich
damals
und ja so nicht eigentlich so sally
gekommen
bin dann zurück nach der messe die firma
hat mit meinen marketing kollegen
gesprochen habe gesagt leute wenn sie
uns diese an gruppe damals wo sie
lehrerin war und keine stelle bekommen
hat obwohl sind super abschlusszeugnis
gemacht gehabt hat und und dann hat er
mit youtube weiter gemacht und ihr papa
war so enttäuscht weil ihr papa da ist
so ein lieber und der wollte immer dass
die lehrerin wird das war sein ganzer
stolz und haben macht zelle mit youtube
weiter unter par vor traurigkeit folge
meint es klassisch aber wenn papa heute
sieht
was sie gemacht hat dann bricht er jedes
mal brennen aus
das ist so krass
und wundervoll was sie macht mit
dem einfachen mit einem einfachen
kompakt kanal
und und wenn du die zuschauer sich wenn
auf messen gehen
und die leute die noch nie gesehen hat
und die haben dann umarmen oder die
eltern hierher kommen und sagen durch
dich
hat meine kleine tochter kochen backen
gelernt und sie kocht und backt für die
ganze familie das ist so emotional
jedesmal und und mit den menschen auf
augenhöhe zu sein wenn wir zum beispiel
auf messen gehen oder auf events gehen
dann dann sind ja meistens ist ja so
dass man auf einer bühne steht und sli
ist immer wichtig dass sie nicht auf
einer bühne steht die sagen ich möchte
keine bühne ich möchte immer auf dem
boden seinen menschen die augen schauen
und und und und ich möchte keine fans
sich zuschauer haben mit zuschauer bis
zum auf augenhöhe fans sind menschen die
ihren starrsinn und von unten nach oben
schauen dass walt disney sie wollte
immer dass die menschen auf augenhöhe
sind und egal was sie gemacht hat ja
immer versucht und bei den menschen auf
augenhöhe zu bleiben und ich denke halt
einfach es ist krass was hier in
waghäusel passiert ist und was die frau
einfach immer wieder geschafft hat
obwohl es den menschen nicht zugetraut
haben und dieser eine tag der war wie so
ein vakuum in der welt weil es war
absolute fröhlichkeit dorsten menschen
in gesichter geschaut die ein jahr lang
oder zwei jahre lang auf diesen moment
gewartet haben die sally zu sehen diese
frau also sally ist wirklich eine
perfektionistin
dadurch dass er auch so ehrgeizig ist
weiß sie immer was sie möchte sie hat
ihr ziel vor augen und
an dieses sie kommen wir immer immer
egal was ist dieses ziel werden wir
immer erreichen
du kannst ihr 10.000 steine in den weg
legen die 10.000 steine sind alle dann
hinterher für mich ist sie die größte
power frau die ich kennenlernen durfte
und
hoffentlich noch weiter kennenlernen
alias sonne so eine person das wenn sie
den raum betritt dass der ganze raum
strahlt weil sie halt einfach so
strahlte sie versucht dir immer positive
energie zu geben und das schafft sie
immer also wir sind alle immer super gut
gelaunt zusammen und haben mega viel
spaß und das macht es
einfach so einfach mit ihr zu arbeiten
zusammenarbeit mit celle ist schrecklich
also man kommt irgendwie an man kriegt
muffins
muss dann singen und tanzen und lachen
den ganzen tag also
für mich persönlich eine tortur
ja zusammenarbeit ist leichtigkeit also
arbeitstage wirken nicht wie arbeitstage
weil eben alles so leicht von hand geht
mit ihr und es kommt alles so natürlich
von daher
wie man vergisst nach kurzer zeit das
man eigentlich hier ist um sachen zu
machen und zu arbeiten
wenn man die regie mit ihr macht dann
ist das wie fernsehschauen und setzt
sich von monitor sagt bitte kelly
liefert ab ohne einen fehler und sagt
kat und der tag ist drin deswegen arbeit
ist zu viel gesagt es ist wirklich eine
große freude mit sally zu arbeiten und
ich freue mich jedes jahr wieder darauf
dass mit ihr zu tun weil es einfach spaß
macht das ist wie ein kleiner urlaub
also beruflich haben wir zu tun gehabt
als wir die ersten kochbücher für sie
gedruckt haben
auch da war sie für mich einzigartig
weil sie trotzdem dass sie in der
digitalen welt zu hause ist er
für das haptische ist das papier was
lebt so dass man da auch sieht wie
verbunden sie ist mit der natur also
einfach sagt wenn sie so ein buch in der
hand hat ist was ganz anderes wie wenn
sie nur eine
bildschirm etwas anschaut also struktur
und überblick egal wenn noch so wuselig
wir hatte ja schon mal modeschauen so da
waren alle nervlich am ende mit der
ganze kinder dadurch völlig entspannt
und höhe alles super macht ihr das ich
hätte eigentlich am diebstahl in der
luft zerrissen völlig tiefenentspannt
und ja und das gleichen sie glaube ich
als dass sie wirklich so ein schritt
zurück der überblick immer hat egal auch
wenn ohne ziemlich viel gewusel ich muss
ja habe weil der unternehmensgröße
mittlerweile aber sie hat trotzdem
absoluten durchblick mit einer ruhe und
vor allem im etikett hier geräten
also ich sehe euch der hut vor ihrer
zehn jahre youtube und immer noch so
perfekt und immer noch wirklich
leute die sie
liebend gerne abonnieren der wahnsinnige
zehn jahre überlegter diesmal das ist
echt echt viel normalerweise ist es
immer selbst die sind wollen ja da und
dann puff ist wieder weg aber wirklich
zehn jahre ja ich wünsche mir für sie
dass sie einfach
die kraft behält und das
durchhaltevermögen hat
und und einfach an ihre gute laune
weiterhin so rüberbringen kann wie sie
es jetzt natürlich tut kann das ist
schon sehr schwierig das muss ich also
ich bestaune jedes mal egal was ist die
seele kann trotz allem in ihrer videos
locker und das richtig gut rüber bringen
als ich schon dass ich der hufe ihr
chateau wirklich
die frau kann hat auch einfach alles sie
kann alles und sie macht es mit einer
professionalität die ist bewundernswert
das einzige was sie nicht kann das bei
sportarten ich glaube dass das einzige
was sie erlebt haben
aber sonst kann sie alles
an jeder wand im ganzen haus im ganzen
welt wirst du diese hände oder
handabdrücke gesehen ich kann mich
erinnern die steinwände zb haben wir mit
dem papa mit dass amira michaela an
weihnachten gemacht über die ganzen
weihnachtsfeiertage wir haben immer
schon alles selber gemacht weil wir
immer alles spüren wollten alles was du
geschenkt bekommst dass das schätzt du
nicht wert sei es der glaube zb sei es
irgendwelche produkte oder irgendwas tun
so wohl fühlen und nicht kämpfen muss
das wofür nicht sparen muss ist das
schätzt du nicht wert deswegen machen
wir alles immer selber und die ganzen
haus baut rüben schon oder jetzt in
berlin das haben wir wirklich
größtenteils nicht alles wir hatten mal
freunde und unternehmer die uns
unterstützt haben alles selber gemacht
und da gab es die situation auch in
meinem leben wo ich mich auch nochmal an
die serie verliebt habe das weiß ich
noch und zwar als sie schwanger war also
ich hab mein kind auf die welt gebracht
aber ich kann es mir vorstellen dass es
sehr schmerzhaft ist und als sally vor
der entscheidung stand wie sie das kind
auf die welt bringen wollte sagt sie
möchte es ging natürlich auf die welt
bringen und ich halte man als als männer
krebs sagte was sagt sie ja ich will das
kind noch mal auf die welt bringen warum
dann sagt sie ich möchte spüren ich
möchte spüren wie das kind auf die welt
bekommt und ich möchte das kind wenn ich
es denn habe auf dem arm habe möchte ich
in vollen bewusstsein sein ich möchte
das kind anschauen ich möchte daran
riechen ich möchte das erlebnis haben
und kind normal auf die welt zu bringen
und es war ein heutzutage immer weniger
menschen dabei ist es das die beste art
und weise ein kind auf die welt zu
bringen ich möchte niemand angreifen
vielleicht könntest manche leute nicht
also setzt er mit ihr nach er hatte die
geburt der kinder war mit abstand das
allerschönste
was wir erlebt haben wir dürften das
jetzt drei mal mehr oder weniger
gemeinsam auch erleben und einmal bei
erlass geburt dann halt auch wirklich
hautnah
und dieser moment wenn man einfach
sozusagen jemand ich glaube in seiner
verletzlichsten sensibelsten
natürlichsten situationen erlebt einfach
kindern ein neues leben zu schenken
das sind einfach dinge die ich glaube
die kann man gar nicht beschreiben also
ich glaube jeder der
aktiv passiv bei einer geburt dabei war
der weiß also in dem moment da steht
einfach die zeit still alles andere wird
so unwichtig weil es einfach unwichtig
ist na also da der blick gerade so ein
neuer mensch
die welt und alles wird so unwichtig und
das war einfach auch so einer der
momente also wir haben gar nicht
gesprochen also ich weiß noch mal mein
erster satz
war
sie hat moritz haben
wir haben in unserem leben alles
erreicht was wir erreichen wollen
sogar viel mehr viel mehr mein wunsch
war immer eine drei zimmer wohnung und
garten das war mein wunsch jetzt haben
ein bisschen mehr aber aber die menschen
der mensch hat sich nicht verändert also
mir werden auch egal was wir gemacht
hätten wir das gemacht hätten und das
gemacht hätten mit der frau werde ich
immer glücklich gewesen und glücklich
seid ist erfolgreich geld ist nicht
erfolgreich sein glücklichsein ist das
aller aller wichtigste gesunde familie
zu haben gesunde kinder zu haben das ist
das schöne im leben als ich den laden
geschlossen wo es ja immer dabei war und
uns unterstützt was wirklich an meiner
seite der 230 im geschäft bei mir und
wurde ja noch mal viele gedreht mit
manuka und so und
das war einfacher intensive zeit also
sie hat merker weint als ich und
es hat mich aber trotzdem dadurch
bestärkt auf der lade was besonderes war
und das gefühl hat sie mir immer gegeben
nicht weil ja
die zu beschreiben ist eigentlich ganz
einfach aber irgendwie doch wieder
schwer weil es gibt keine worte die sie
beschreiben es ist der ist dieser
mindset na also
egal wie schwierig der dreh ist oder wie
schwierig die aufgaben sind man hat
immer so das gefühl es geht er so leicht
von der hand also sie hatte einfach so
ein naturell an sich dass
wir die schwersten situationen einfach
macht na also sieht auf jeden fall
spielen leicht aus wahrscheinlich ist es
dass für sie nicht aber
hast du die die diese diese ruhe diese
energie diese
auch dieses dieses kindische
diesen kindischen leicht sind diese den
sie in sich trägt wenn sie dann
irgendwie singt und tanzt und lacht
das ist schon etwas besonderes
wie würde ich sehr liebe schreiben dass
tatsächlich schwierig also ich war jetzt
eher dafür dass wir sally artig sally in
den duden auflegen also vielleicht hat
ja jemand zu in die wege leiten kann ja
weil einfach also um sie zu beschreiben
glaube ich was gibt es dafür für wörter
also ich meine sie kann alles sie hat
gefühl 20 ar mit zehn beine um im alltag
als mama hausfrau frau geschäftsführerin
auf die beine zu stellen
nett zuvorkommend
immer gut drauf also so kann ich sagt
dass sie trotz ihren gigantischen erfolg
so normal geblieben ist ohne
irgendwelche allüren da sie immer noch
sie selbst verkörpert und einfach
geblieben ist wie sie ist punkt eins ist
sie hat eine wahnsinnig starke
ausstrahlung also das was ich denke
in den videos rüberkommt erstrahlt sie
auch im wahren leben aus also sie sie
umgibt so eine gewisse aura und sie hat
eine wahnsinnige ausstrahlung
sli macht besonders dass sie einfach
besonders ist mehr kann ich dazu gar
nicht sagen
viele viele viele tolle momente mit dir
ich kann gar nicht ein rausnehmen es
gibt zu viele
es gibt echt zu viel keine ahnung
zu krass privat
weißt du die die sally ist für mich wie
eine kleine schwester die ist einfach
ein
extrem liebenswerter mensch
der immer da ist vorgestern habe ich sie
besucht und was haben wir gemacht wenn
wir uns am tisch gesetzt und wir haben
einfach zusammen kurz was gegessen oder
sie kocht schnell was oder wenn wir im
urlaub sind das ist alles ich glaube
viele leute haben die vorstellung von
sli dass sie irgendwie ein star ist oder
so was das mögen alle glauben nur sie
glaubt es nicht und das ist glaube das
was sie ausmacht dass sie das nie sein
will wie ist und und sie ist einfach wie
sie ist und dafür für diese
bodenständigkeit
muss man sie einfach lieben muss sagen
was ich aber immer meisten genieße ist
wenn wir fertig gedreht haben und der
ganze tag so durch ist und den ganzen
tag irgendwas gemacht haben abends mit
mit murat und mit ihr tee trinken so
dann wird eigentlich immer dann dann ist
irgendwie immer die schönsten und
entspanntesten privaten momente das
macht immer das dann das am schönsten da
freue ich mich immer irgendwie am
meisten weil es so einfach tut gut um um
euch um zu sein dass das rechte an will
der schönste moment mit sally war
eindeutig unser flüsterpost spiel
seitdem hat das wort mayonnaise eine
ganz andere bedeutung für mich ein ganz
besonderer moment war eigentlich unsere
erste ifa in berlin
wo wir ja alle von der blackbox
standen wie kommt das an wie es die
resonanz wir haben natürlich schon
tendenzen gehabt weil murat schon gesagt
hat also zieht euch warm an da wird
richtig was los sein und man muss sich
vorstellen auf der ifa wir haben nahezu
eine ganze halle also das sind dann
schon ordentliche dimensionen da ist
sehr viel platz da passen auch viele
menschen rein
und wir hatten relativ zentral unseren
kochbereich unsere showbühne boselli
dann aufgetreten ist und
ja das war eigentlich für mich in
absolut wahnsinniger moment zu sehen wo
das erst einmal sally aufgetreten ist
damals auf der ifa ja was was das
eigentlich für eine resonanz ausgelöst
hatten also ich will ja sagen wir wir
mussten die halle fasst sperren aber es
war wirklich so dass das sich dermaßen
viele menschen dann um sally versammelt
haben ja dass das für alle bachelor
total beeindruckend war und für mich
auch und ja wir sind uns eigentlich
danach einfach nur kurz in die arme
gefallen und ich habe gesagt das ist
absolut wahnsinn was da passiert ist und
das war so ganz besonderer moment einer
wie gesagt von ganz vielen also ich
denke wir haben viele tolle schöne
momente gehabt aber das war für mich
moment wo ich sage
der war für mich ja meilenstein in der
zusammenarbeit und für mich ist es
einfach super wurden
einfach ein unglaublicher mensch
der die alles was sie gemacht hat zu
einer prozent verdient hat
jetzt
also
fix und fertig ist okay
da musste ich schon stolz
wahnsinn
wir als gewinner vom feld zu gehen es
ist alles weg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlichen glückwunsch
sally
druck gut gemacht nicht nur zehnjähriges
auch zwei millionen läuft bei dir das
mal langsam wieder einholen jetzt sehr
schrecklich
ganz liebe grüße das handy auf gar
keinen fall missen nicht mal eine
einzige minute
[Gelächter]
und
wünsche ihr eine ganz tolle zeit haben
eine ganz ganz tolle zeit fälle du
machst das großartig
herzlichen glückwunsch
liebe sally in zehn jahren hast du sie
zu einer überaus erfolgreichen
vor allem aber sympathischen michael
gemacht mit jugendlichem tatendrang
kreativen ideen künstlerisch
ambitioniert immer professionell und
perfekt in der umsetzung mit einem mann
und einer familie die sally mit dir
leben und mit einem großartigen team
meine herzlichsten glückwünsche an dich
und dein ganzes system zu zehn jahren
erfolgsgeschichte
liebe sally lieber murat und natürlich
das ganze team von salis welt wie von
youtube mit glückwünschen euch zu eurem
zehnjährigen youtube jubiläum und einem
weiteren meilenstein nämlich zwei
millionen abonnenten auf youtube seit
nunmehr 2011 begeistern ihren dass
youtube publikum regelmäßig mit eure
leidenschaft für großartige rezepte mit
über 580 millionen user die deutschlands
größter youtube creator im bereich
kochen und backen ihr seid ein
leuchtendes beispiel dafür dass starke
ideen die community bewegen und erfolg
auf youtube auch zu euren erfolg als
unternehmer beiträgt wirtschaft
arbeitsplätze veröffentlicht eingekocht
bücher entwickelt produkte und verkauft
sie online und offline in eurem eigenen
flagship store wir sind stolz darauf
dass ihr seit nunmehr über zehn jahren
auf youtube woche für woche euren
zahlreichen zuschauern lehrreiche tipps
für küche und haushalt gibt und du sally
damit deine leidenschaft zum beruf
machen konnte alles gute weiterhin
ich weiß jetzt nicht wie es jetzt weiter
geht aber das schöne ist halt wir haben
uns auch unseren traum erfüllt weil wir
arbeiten da wo wir leben das heißt wenn
wir arbeiten gehen da gehen wir nur die
garage und sind schon bei unserer arbeit
und manchmal ist ein bisschen viel muss
man ganz ganz ehrlich sagen wir müssen
auch mehr mehr uns ab und zu mal
zurückziehen aber das ding ist einfach
das was wir machen machen wir gerne aus
vollem herzen es macht spaß es ist keine
last aber trotzdem ist uns ab und zu mal
bremsen ich weiß nicht wohin der weg
geht cdu noch geht jetzt haben wir die
zehn jahre geschafft keine ahnung was
wir im nächsten jahr noch machen werden
aber ich bin mir ganz ganz sicher die
sally ist für ganz ganz große
überraschung gut
wichtig ist dass wir uns treu bleiben
wichtig ist dass wir hier in waghäusel
bleiben
das ist wichtig und dass wir uns
gegenseitig unterstützen und zwar als
familie aber auch mit mit den leuten
eine freundin die wir haben soll wünsche
ich alles gute so weiter so und
ich hab so in meinem herzen ich glaube
ich muss jetzt aufhören
ich gehe jetzt mein klub houston daten
[Musik]